I trained dogs a lot and there's a
phrase that you use all the time let the
puppy win to build their confidence now
I don't want to hurt anybody that's not
as strong and as quick as I am William
Shatner throws major sci-fi shade at
Mark Hamill do not interfere but Luke
Skywalker is prepared to battle I warn
you not to underestimate my power when
he hears about Shatner's remarks mark
fires back on Twitter and historical
first Canada instigating conflict I may
have the force but the farce is with
William Shatner poor man he needs his
confidence built big changes are coming
for the Star Trek franchise the new TV
series Star Trek Discovery will put a
modern spin on Captain Kirk by having a
woman of color leave the show a black
woman that's not unusual to me we've had
green people we've had black people
we've had brown people I know there's no
plans for William to show up in the new
series he's busy taking a stab at the
reality TV world with his new project
better late than never
a show that finds him checking off a
bizarre bucket list you should see what
I'm saying I want to get in the ring
with George Foreman two-time heavyweight
champion of the world I got in the ring
and he punched me out wonderful it's a
real privilege to play Bryan Mills booth
what's nice about it is it's Bryan
before he acquires a particular set of
skills Viking star Clive Stanton has
taken on aniconic role made famous by
Liam Neeson skills I have acquired over
a very long career the takin TV series
is coming out next winter and serves as
a prequel to the movies and Clive's
already got that famous phone call scene
down pat I don't know who you are
even gives it a personalized twist why
time travel shows us are so interesting
what changes would severely affect the
future Willa graces eric mccormack finds
himself time traveling to save the human
race in his new series travelers come to
showcase and Netflix this fall
travelers are here to fix elements of
the presence but if he could travel back
in time in real life what would he
change I'd change what I wore in 1932
words velour